[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشهور الهجريه شهور تعتمد على حركه القمر
ولهذا تسمى الشهور الهلاليه ليله واحد
يغيب القمر وحيده مغيب الشمس ليله اثنين
يغيبوا القمر بينماغيب الشمس الى مغيب
الشفق الاحمر ليله ثلاثه يغيب القمر مع
مغيب الشفق الاحمر يوم 14 يشرق القمر شرقا
مع مغيب شمس غربا والعامه يعرفون تمام
الشهر من نقصانه من تبدر القمر فاذا تبدر
يوم 14 كان شهر هافي 29 يوما واذا تبذر
يوم 15 كان شهر وافي ثلاثين يوما فالشهور
الهجريه شهور كونيه ليست شهور اصطلاحيه
كحاله شهور الميلاديه فهي تعتمد على ظاهره
كونيه مشاهده بالعيان والعامه يعرفون
اليوم من اشكال القمر سيذكرني قومي اذا جد
جدهم وفي الليله الظلماء يفتقد
البدر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والقمر يشاهد 28 يوما ولهذا منازله 28
منزله والمنازل هي المحطات التي يستريح
بها القمر اثناء رحلته الشهريه حول الارض
فاذا كان شهر 29 يوما فانه يستتر لليله
واحده ان يختفي واذا كان ثلاثين يوما فانه
يختفي لليلتين وتسمى ليالي الاستسرار رايت
الهلال ووجه الحبيب فكان هلالين عند النظر
فلم ادري من حيرته